ah doctor may be against banter but I'm
not robots of Sherwood I was looking
forward to going back to this one now it
here's the thing let me be upfront I
really enjoyed this episode but I also
know that a lot of folks don't and I
can't even argue that they're wrong
liking an episode like this really does
come down to a matter of personal taste
much more so than I think usually
happens with a doctor because not to
treat the fandom like a homogenous
single unit that all thinks the same way
but we all enjoy Doctor Who and most of
us tend to enjoy similar things about it
so there are certain things that you can
do that are usually going to please most
the fandom and certain things you can do
that are you're going to take off most
of the fandom but there are some things
that don't normally come up in the
course of Doctor Who that then become
the thing that people either like or
they don't and that aren't normally part
of this mix in this case the tone on
this that light cheeky preposterous kind
of adventure and the ridiculousness of a
character like Robin has he is portrayed
here which is very camp and very
over-the-top this was the sort of thing
that you can find it every now and then
in classic who it didn't really come up
in new who um not in anything that you
know worked I mean one could argue that
loved' Monsters is a bit camp but I
think the problems would that episode go
a lot further than not liking a camp
aspect so for me I really enjoy this
episode and I enjoy it for basically the
same reason that I really like the show
legends of tomorrow it's just so much
fun
and I also like the decision
do Robin Hood basically taking advantage
of the fact that that frees them up
because for the most part when doctor
who has tackled real-life historical
figures it's usually tried to do them
some degree of justice a part of that
owing to the fact that more often than
not they are aggrandizing these
historical figures which honestly can be
its own minefield but that's a
discussion I don't really feel like
having right now but by picking a legend
something that everyone has heard of but
probably didn't really exist you can
just play and just have fun with all the
the the tropes and the iconography of
the character and not worry about well
the real Robin Hood wasn't like that
because there probably wasn't a real
Robin Hood in the first place
so getting to just play with that and
not have to worry about the accuracy of
it not have to worry about you know are
we over grand i0 are we bringing down
this character or like anything like
that not that I'm sure not that I'm
convinced Doctor Who actually spends a
lot of time thinking about that but I
think there's at least somewhere in the
mix because no historical figure has
been his over the top as Robin Hood is
so it really does feel like kind of the
reins came off the leash got loosened
and they really got to just go nuts I
love the guy they got to play Robin Hood
he is so much fun he is clearly having a
blast but also they do enough little
touches so that his portrayal does still
feel human as exaggerated as it is and
the smart thing that was done because
what what wouldn't have worked is if he
was very boisterous all the way through
and then he tried to like have a more
somber moments just at the end but early
on when Marian his first meeting all the
rest of these people and all of merry
men and she says you know you're you're
sad he's like I why do you say that
because the doctors right you laugh too
much and he'd like he has a little
vulnerable moment so it's seeding early
on that the bravado is to a certain
extent on act because the guy's been
through a lot and it's not all been good
so I I do
really enjoy that getting seated in
there early as well
the sheriff is fine he's workable as as
a sheriff he he just needs to be
dastardly and self-serving and yeah he
does that it works
I also rather like that it's established
that the doctor won the archery
tournament by cheating not so much that
I liked the idea of the doctor cheating
in and of itself about totally works for
me but it means that the doctor just
didn't also happen to be a massively
skilled Archer there's there's needs to
be a limit on how many things the doctor
is really good at and so I like that
that turned out to be the case there oh
one total nitpick on the archery
tournament though and look I I have a
longbow I do archery I or you know what
I can I don't have my own I don't have
my own range to be able to do it at but
I've always enjoyed archery and it just
drives me crazy at the archery
tournament especially when they move the
target further away that they're aiming
level basically parallel to the ground
arrows aren't bullets they don't fly I
mean bullets have drop-off if you go far
enough but for how far away that target
was they needed to be angled up at least
about there and they're just firing dead
at it I'm like no that's gonna go in the
dirt about ten feet short of the target
and that just annoys me but that's one
of those things where like I'm burdened
by knowledge I know just a little bit
too much about our tree to realize that
like that's not how that works so minor
nitpick there as far as the overall
thing goes here's here's the thing I
liked I liked that none of the major
players involved in this are actually
aliens because again another bit of a
recurring thing for me is for is the
fact that doctor who has a tendency to
go oh what's this what's this thing and
it's like it's a it's a monster or it's
this historical thing or this
mythological thing is like is aliens I
might hear that even though they tease
out the possibility neither the sheriff
nor Robin Hood nor
eva's Merriman none of them are aliens
none of them don't belong here the only
thing that's that don't belong are just
these Knights generic-looking Knights so
I like that they didn't try and pull the
similar sort of oh it's this thing that
you've heard of but it's actually aliens
which is never surprising at this point
because it's what they do every day and
time another thing that I really like I
mentioned in my little intro joke liking
the banter I love the banter so here's
the thing if if the performance of Robin
Hood was not delivered the way it was
and if his banter and frustration
chemistry with the doctor was not as
good as it is this could have been a
very flat episode it really does ride on
the overall tone and the strength of
personality and if either of those
things aren't to your liking yeah this
isn't gonna work for you but since I
enjoyed both of those in this case
although I should be clear I don't feel
like the tone of this thing should ever
be what dr. who is normally I like it as
a sort of a breather a little breath of
fresh air and a different taking a
different vibe to things so that's part
of why I like this so much I would never
wanted to become the standard for Doctor
Who but as an occasional yeah I like it
but what I was getting at was with the
bandra specially with the doctor
complaining about the banter I really
like here that they do a very good job
of justifying how grouchy Capaldi's
doctor is because I haven't rewatched
series eight in a while but my general
memory you know thinking back on series
eight nine ten was that he started very
grouchy got basically maybe swung a
little bit too far in the other
direction trying to you know be cool and
like get people to like him and then
sort of settling in a nice happy medium
and ten that's part of his character arc
that I really enjoy across the series
but it is nice to come back to series
eight and see an episode like this where
yes he's grouchy and he's kind of been
established has a bit of a grouchy
character but I totally get it
this Robin Hood has the exact kind of
personality that is going to irritate
the heck out of this particular doctor
and it makes his grouchy is fully
justified whereas again we'll see how my
memory holds up to my memory there
instances later on where it doesn't feel
as justified actually I even brought it
up in the previous review for into the
Dalek where it didn't feel fully
justified with him having the issues
with the soldier it just felt a little
arbitraries a little too strong a word
but it just felt like forced grouchiness
force issues for him to have so I like
that if they're gonna have him be this
sort of crotchety that they find ways to
organically bring it out of him through
the situation the people they ask to
interact with rather than just having it
be a default setting for his personality
so I enjoyed that quite a bit
Clare's working this you know it's
something I really like about this um
it's funny because I forgotten that it
happens at all and if you're not paying
attention it could just read as like a
lame joke but it's actually very telling
so there's the scene this is after the
archery tournament where Robin the
doctor and Clara all three of them are
in this cell they're all chained up so
what happens is the guard comes and says
he's going to take the leader and Robin
and the doctor starts arguing over which
one of them it is and he takes Clara now
that feels like just a joke in and of
itself but the thing is if you realize
that that guard had been outside the
door and been listening to them for a
little while to figure out who he was
gonna take this makes total sense
because these two are arguing and this
one is the one who says shut up you say
your plan okay now you say your plan so
I it it actually feeds off of that and
that works quite well and also what I
like about that moment and that
interaction is it really plays into
Clara's new position as a teacher if
you've ever known a teacher someone who
has to deal with kids who don't always
get along and be like okay stop this
this let's sort this and that's the tone
that she basically adopts right then so
I totally buy it now that they've
established that she is teaching out of
school so they this real
is in many ways Clara feels like a
brand-new character in series 8 and I
don't mean that in a way that they
completely altered her and like rewrote
her from the ground up
I mean there's foundational
justification for why she is the way she
is that it really felt like series 7
didn't bother to do cuz it was too busy
going hrough isn't she mysterious and
somehow they felt lacking details on her
was gonna add to the mystery but now
that that's all behind us we get to
watch how being a teacher influences the
way she deals with someone like the
doctor and she just gets that
authoritative tone that teachers dealing
with her IV kids will get and so I
actually really liked that moment so
here's the thing I have a tendency to
groan about Clara
in general I groan about her because of
how she starts and how she ends but I
said before and I this is holding up
that she did grow on me and her time
with Capaldi I don't like the entire
mystery of the impossible girl aside
from the fact that I think is kind of a
lame series second half of a series arc
in the first place in addition to that
she just feels completely under
characterized especially versus the two
iterations we'd met for only an episode
of peas previous to that and I also
uh-huh we'll get there have a lot of
issues with hellbent so I have this
trajectory with Clara where she starts
low gets better actually gets quite good
and then nosedives at the very end and a
lot of that is not again I want to
stress this not Jenna Coleman it's not
the performance it is character use and
writing primarily so it is nice to go
back and watch series eight again and
remember yes she did grow on me she was
working better for me at this point as
these things go and these sort of
interactions are a big part of why and
she and compelled users have great
chemistry just little things like him
prompting her to make the decision of
where they go and then be like no we're
not gonna do that and trying to talk her
into something else but she just puts
her
down on it it's just it's the it's just
the right amount of adversarial and I
think the last thing I wanted to mention
I really like the moment towards the end
with Robin and the doctor where you know
Robin says saw I'll just be thought of
as a legend well good
history is a burden and you know I'm not
a hero but maybe I can inspire other
people to try and be and he relates that
to the doctor because the doctor has
been asking am i a good man he's
questioning his own value as a hero as a
good person and Robin Hood is laying out
you don't have to be perfect but you can
still be inspiring regardless and
there's value in that I was nice to see
that sort of sink in for Capaldi to hear
it oh one other minor thing I'm gonna
try and keep an eye on this to see if
they address it but it's bugging me
right now that so far the whole promised
land and heaven thing which ties into
Missy so got introduced in deep breath
it gets reiterated here because that's
where the robots are trying to get to is
the promised land why robots in my
memory of the plan and everything else
for how death and heaven worked was that
she needed the minds of people who had
been alive so I'm gonna have to keep an
ear out to see if we get an explanation
as to why she would have been
interacting at all with robots
implanting the idea of promised lands
into robots and and you know clockwork
cyborg kind of things in the case of in
the case of deep breath I mean deep
breath I was prepared to let go because
that one actually plants the idea that
you know he he had replaced so many
parts with so many different people that
he just kind of through osmosis I guess
kind of absorbed the idea and some of
the concept
underlie the majority of humanity like
the idea of a promised land and while
that's a very soft science explanation
it was enough for me to let it go in
that case but now we've got robots
straight up robots these are robots with
a mechanical ship try and get to the
promised land
what and even if there is like you're
gonna argue it like well the aliens and
they may be the alias time the crash
it's just their automated stuff that's
trying to get there and it was the
aliens goal to get to the promised land
we also see no aliens involved in death
and heaven it's all about humans so I
got I gotta I'm gonna see if I can
remember to keep an eye on that because
I'm starting to feel like it doesn't
track the way that they try and
reiterate that mystery box we'll see I
think that will about wrap it up for me
robots of Sherwood have you rewashed it
lately what are your thoughts on it I
really do enjoy it whatever your
thoughts are dropped something on down
in the comments let's talk about it oh
and if you do enjoy it have you seen
legends of tomorrow cuz if not do that
power through the first season it's got
two really lousy characters who are gone
out the first season after that it's
gold
um so usual stuff you know it is like
and subscribe and patreon and socials
etc etc that are links in the
description all that stuff so that's it
for this time and you don't have to do
any of the stuff I mentioned if you
don't want to because end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]